the things Joe Rogan recommended was
Ivermectin here's the thing I don't get
you won't take the vaccine but you will
take Ivermectin I mean that you know
good old Ivermectin
there's a product I can try and by the
way if you're looking for advice from a
former host of The Man Show call me next
time okay because I have a
I have a second opinion on this
Ivermectin does work you should talk to
your doctor okay fine but they it's not
that they just go after those with a
platform why are they going after Rogan
why did CNN spend those weeks going
after Rogan it was because Rogan was
bigger than CNN it wasn't because they
thought he was racist right you guys all
know that but they will also go after
you if you make a choice in your life
you know I'd prefer not to be injected
with their experimental medication
that's something that I would prefer not
to do or I certainly don't want to be
forced into it they will literally go
after you